In the years since the Harry Potter film franchise
wrapped up, its cast members have gone on
to plenty of new projects, finding fresh opportunities
beyond the world of witches and wizards and
outside the hallowed halls of Hogwarts.
And that includes Evanna Lynch, who brought
Luna Lovegood to life when she joined the
film series in its fifth installment, Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix.
Lynch may have been a latecomer to the massive
Potter franchise,
but she was a very welcome addition.
The Irish actress, who grew up reading the
Harry Potter books, added whimsy and heart
to the films as Luna, an intelligent and eccentric
Ravenclaw student who believes in some of
the weirdest magical theories around.
As a part of Harry's core group, Luna fights
alongside him and his friends at the end of
Order of the Phoenix as they face off against
evil Death Eaters.
She more than proved her worth in the fifth
Harry Potter flick, and from that point on,
Luna is an integral part of the plot.
And Lynch became an integral part of the franchise
behind the scenes as well, right from the
moment she went to an open casting call for
the role in 2006.
Lynch was already a huge fan of the books
and the films, and had even sent letters to
Harry Potter author J.K.
Rowling well before she became a part of the
franchise.
She told Lorraine Kelly,
"So, yeah, I wrote to her, and she wrote back.
And we became friends, and we became, well,
pen friends, before I got the role."
Though she had been in contact with Rowling
prior to auditioning, Lynch won the coveted
role of Luna fair and square, beating out
a reported 15,000 other young girls who auditioned
to play Luna and impressing during her screen
test with Radcliffe.
Lynch was practically born to play the bright-eyed
witch, and the minds behind the film knew
it; producer David Heyman even said,
"The others could play Luna; Evanna Lynch
is Luna."
Rowling has also admitted that as she finished
the final books in the Harry Potter novel
series, she envisioned Lynch while writing
Luna's scenes.
Lynch clearly tasted the sweetness of success
during her years-long, four-movie turn as
Luna Lovegood, and luckily for the talented
actress, she's continued landing roles after
the Harry Potter franchise ended in 2011,
both in film and on the stage.
The actress has booked a number of roles in
live theater, appearing as Luna Lovegood in
2012's A Very Potter Senior Year, as Bess
Houdini in Peter Snee's 2013 production Houdini,
as Runt in the 2017-2018 stage adaptation
of the Irish film Disco Pigs, as Gaby in 2019's
The Omission of the Family Coleman, and as
Martha in director Anthony Banks' Games for Lovers.
On the film side of things, Lynch moved away
from blockbusters after Harry Potter ended
and appeared in several smaller films, including
My Name is Emily, G.B.F., and the British
television movie Danny and the Human Zoo.
Lynch also played Theresa Bornstein in the
true-life film Dynamite: A Cautionary Tale,
and had a cameo role in Jason Mewes' Madness
in the Method.
Lynch's after-Potter adventures also took
her to the small screen.
She's popped up on an episode of the action-adventure
series Sinbad, as well as on the pilot episode
of Apex.
The actress also lent her voice to three different
characters, Academy Voice, Tablet, and Lunchbox,
on Nickelodeon's animated "Nicktoon" Middle
School Moguls.
Lynch's highest profile turn since playing
Luna Lovegood came during her time across
the pond on the 27th season of ABC's Dancing
With the Stars.
Along with her dance partner, Keo Motsepe
[KEE-oh moats-EH-pay], she ultimately finished
the competition in third place.
Beyond her professional life, Lynch has also
maintained a personal brand dedicated to health
and wellness, openly discussing her struggles
with eating disorders and becoming an advocate
for body positivity.
"I was battling an eating disorder.
Anyone who's had an eating disorder knows,
it completely takes over your life.
And the only thing that could actually take
my attention apart from that was the Harry
Potter series."
And she is also a vegan activist, even co-founding
a vegan beauty box with fellow actress and
activist Daniella Monet.
After seeing Lynch come of age on the big
screen, it's gratifying for fans to know that
she continues to thrive.
The actress clearly has a bright future ahead
of her between her stage work, film career,
and activism.
Though the Potter series is over, it's obvious
that Lynch is here to stay.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.